researchers have set up a system that
lets them see mutations in living cells
and follow the cell's fates good bad or
neutral spontaneous mutations are not
easy to detect in a living system but
there are important unanswered questions
about how mutations are distributed and
how common they are this information
makes it possible to use the mutation
rate of organisms to look back in time
to see when two related species diverged
in this field
the mother cells are along the top of a
microfluidic chip so named because
narrow channels control the liquids flow
in very specific ways the offspring but
off and expand into the tiny tubes each
cell pinched off from its progenitor
newly made cells are whisked away by
liquid at the bottom of the tube
bacteria are red and replication error
machinery markers from mutation are the
yellow dots the researchers followed
bacterial cells over 200 generations to
look for mutations and the effects those
mutations had they were able to
calculate the rate of deadly mutations
at about 1% much lower than expected
they also found that mutations occur
regularly in individual cells they all
get mutations at pretty much the same
rate regardless of stress level and that
mutations are less detrimental to the
bacteria and than expected this new
technique for tracking mutations and
single cells could be used in cancer
research or to explore different
mutation patterns in different tissues
[Music]